well here we are again oral with ross
stripling in the starting rotation it
seems like it's the same story every
season where he's trying to make a case
for the rotation you think that he's
headed to the bullpen but then for one
reason or another he winds up in the
rotation this time it was opened up by
the opt out of david price
flores with a line drive right over the
head of corey seeger and the first space
runner in this game goes to wilmer
flores
off first is another one-two comes home
and there's that change-up to get
sandoval swinging
that was sweet
not only the change of speed but watch
the depth at the end as this avoids the
barrel of the back the new grip has
really brought on the deception but
especially the movement went back with a
high fastball and got another swing and
a miss for strike three
former conorado rocky tyler anderson
makes his giants debut now here's maxie
monsieur strokes one to right field that
sends davis back it's gone
max muncie with a solo shot to open the
scoring here in the first and he's got
his first of 20 20 here in game two a
real start here for jock oral against a
left-handed pitcher towards right center
field that's gonna get down for a lead
off hit
feeling stronger and more in balance
feels like his body is in a good
position rico garcia who came in last
night as well
comes in here with two on and two out
turner goes after the first pitch and
bends the base hit tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
davis did not see any action in the game
last night
hit well to right
mookie betts back out of here
an opposite field home run for jalen
davis and it's a two to one ball game
muncie's been on both times he homered
in the first he walked in the second
muncie yanks one towards the right field
corner that's hooking away from davis
another base hit from muncie he adds to
the homer on the walk with a double
now justin turner who has walked single
and driven in a run let's drill the left
field that is going to drop in for a
base hit and that's going to roll to the
bullpen gate turner delivers again once
he comes in to score and the dodgers
take a three to one lead think of beauty
back-to-back doubles
for the dodgers just keep the train
[Applause]
he's in the mvp race now
here's taylor
bounced along third taylor
[Applause]
[Music]
gets the elbow to the neck from the
family full of wrestlers no wrestler
himself
tough tough guy chris taylor
he will stay in the game
lifts up so the center field yoshi dives
comes in makes the catch and coming in
to score is seeger it'll be a sacrifice
fly
if
eustress he doesn't have to leave his
feet he may have a shot
he catches it goes into the slot i mean
he really got back
quickly to his feet
but seeger gets back to the bag and he's
got good speed there was no chance for
yastrimsky
nice defensive play
max muncie comes up he's reached off
three times tonight homer in the first
walked in the second doubled in the
fourth
fly ball to center field
[Applause]
they want to go up and in they go low
and away well that's got to be
a red zone for max monkey don't go there
ross tripling is ready he has built
himself up during the down time he came
into camp with the dream of being a
starter he knew he wasn't one of the top
five selections but he never loses focus
on what he wants to be he is the jack of
all trades and master of all and he
wants to get off to another fast start
and ross
with a heck of an outing to debut his
20-20 season seven innings just one run
there goes peterson throw to second gets
by
hernandez
peterson winds up at third and the
dodgers steal a run here
you got to keep this ball in front of
you it's not about the quick release
it's about keeping the ball in front of
you
and then the original throw from
brantley was too low uki looking for his
first hit tonight oh for four
yanked up the midland by crawford for a
base hit off center
in comes peterson the third goes smith
and mookie betts with his first hit of
the night and his first rbi is a dodger
loaded up for taylor like they were in
the first inning when he flied to the
left taylor rips one through the left
side base hit
they go station to station bettinger
scores
after winning 8-1 and opening night they
lead 8-1 here in game two chris taylor
erasing some of the frustration but he
does to get to stand down there with
pablo sandoval and talk a little bit
about tackle football that they played
early
that is a four pitch walk and it'll
bring home the ninth run of the game
so smith gets an easy rbi there's
hernandez steps on home and it's back to
the top of the order for bets rogers on
the verge of a 2-0 start with an 8-1 win
last night a 9-1 lead here
did he go
he did and that does it
for the dodgers with an 8-1 win in game
one a 9-1 win in game two
they pecked at him early on the
offensive side and almost pecked him to
death until the two started coming up at
the end but the guy who really set the
table today was ross stripling
outstanding outing for a game two
starter dustin may game one ross
tripling game two we'll see alex wood
tomorrow